Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to another Try Not to Laugh challenge.
Alright, let's get into it!
EH!
EHH!
I'm preparing the hate in my face. I'm angry. Alright, I'm ready. Let's do this!
[In video] NO JEFF THAT'S NOT HOW YOU GET BAKED!
I'm sorry what?
I'm sorry...
W   H   A   T
ehhhhhh..
im sorry.
W̶̨̱̪̪͔̗̗͇͉͕̒̀̋̐̈́̿̀̉͘͝͠͝ͅ ̷̩͙͕̳̫͈̯͋̊̓͂̓̊́͂̕H̴̢̡̡̡̗̻͉̰̻̠̥̰̗͉̰͂̋̈́͗̎ ̶̡̣͉͈̽̑͘͝Â̷̢̛̛̩̻̖̲͈̰̼̤͑́̓͊̕͠ ̸͓͈̻̤̝̫̯͎̻̩̘̇̄̒̿̽̈́͋͜T̴̤̣̖͍͉̉̿͒̾͐̽̄́̓͒̉̈̕
Greeting fellow Americans.
Do you know how hard it is to grab a cup of coffee?
[Laughing] With the same hand that you're holding in your bread?
I...
Um..
Excuse me, I deh, why were you laughing?
That's cute
that's real cute
very cute!
but not...
not that
F u n n y
ᶜᵒᵐᵉ ʰᵉʳᵉ
N   O   P   E
wHAt
YoU'rE NoT my DaD!! YoU AlWaYs WaNnA HeAr SoMeThInG
UgLy AsS FuCkin NoOdLeHead-
NO!
*♩- love4eva by LOONA  *
Woman in Video: Hello!
Oh My
oooh
That's the face you see right before you die
I'm Megan and you're watching  disney channel
I'm gonna pass out. Hmm. Imma pass out what happened?
what the hell is going on, is this EgGs?
thats very funny
What?
oh
ah~.
ah~
Ah!~
AwWwW~
OhH!
that was..
oh~
Wow, okay. All right
Well, temper tantrum much?
Zaggles let go of the fucking plunger! Don't instigate it! Let go of it-
For fuck sakes let go EW WAS THAT PEE???
EW I STEPPED IN YOUR PEE-
STOP
STOPP
OoOoh spicy! Oh, what is this? I don't like this or wherever it's going
I
HATE
EVERYTHING ABOUT YOU!
Am I alive?
what am I looking at?
oh no
My brain...
MY BRAIN!
aaaa
AAAA
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Okay, all right, ah fuck man, I it's just so perfect
So fucking perfect!
Well shit, that's a loss. Oh, well, let's keep going man. Let's keep gOiNG!
Whatever you're gonna do don't do it...
heh boop
ᵇᵒᵒᵖ
i hate it, oh no i hate this oh no this is gunna be bad
(Video) - Fuckin idiot...
(Guy in front)Come on you fucking idiot!
Pay attention! pay attention!
fuck..
(Video) - Straight up straight up.
I'm so stupid
(Video) - AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
(Video) - AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
I dunno why that is happening
I dunno why any of that is that thing (Wut)
And how can people not laugh at that
Dear diary...
Thank you- everybody so much for watching. If you want to see more try not to laugh
They're available in the description and the suggestive videos over there
There's a playlist there's tons of stuff, and if you want me to see more funny videos that you got
Get them to me however, email... uhhhhh
Twitter...
Instagram whatever. Thank you buddies. That's it :DDD
And uhh, as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye-bye!